a few years ago I officially became a
middle-aged dad by tearing my achilles
during a casual game of pickup
basketball in the driveway short time
later I was at the hospital where after
a long and rather physically agonizing
weight in the waiting room the doctor
gave me Tylenol and told me that I had
to get an MRI and see a specialist a
week later I had finally been officially
diagnosed with a torn Achilles at which
point I was informed of all the options
and the risks that accompany each option
and of course the only reasonable option
was to get a surgery to repair the
Achilles but still I had to be informed
that for example doing nothing and
letting it heal on its own was a path
that could be chosen though it certainly
was not recommended I decided to go with
the surgery
it's all a pretty standard experience
nothing harrowing or really interesting
about that and that's really the point
because here's what didn't happen
I didn't make a 22 minute video call and
get approved for the surgery based on my
claims alone
they didn't give me an Achilles surgery
merely because I said I wanted one they
didn't simply take my word for it
and if the doctor had looked at me and
looked at the MRI and determined that my
achilles was not torn he wouldn't have
given me the surgery anyway just to
affirm my feelings that it was torn
that's not how medicine works unless of
course you work in the gender transition
industry
it's been 24 hours since we published
the results of our undercover
investigation into the single largest
quote-unquote trans health care provider
in the United States the provider we're
talking about is called plume and it
operates in 41 States it's backed by
some of the biggest insurance companies
and VCS in the country and it's totally
fraudulent in case you missed it the
other day after a 22 minute video call
just 22 minutes plume approved one of my
producers for an orchiectomy which means
testicle removal no one at plume had
seen my producer's name as Greg before
that call they didn't verify any of his
of his information which was obviously
made up
they didn't double check the phony legal
name he provided they didn't bat an eye
when Greg identified as Chelsea Bussey
and claimed to be a strong independent
woman in need of immediate castration
no one at plume thought that there was
anything odd about all of this even
though Greg made precisely zero effort
to pass as a woman clearly had no idea
what an orchiectomy would entail or what
it even means plume just rubber stamped
Greg for testicle removal
all he had to do was send 150 bucks for
the letter
and in return plume sent Greg a letter
saying that he has gender dysphoria so
that insurance would pay for his
testicle removal even though he
repeatedly told them that he didn't have
gender dysphoria now let's pause for a
moment to consider one of the ironies of
this whole Saga which Manhattan
Institute fellow lior sapir uh pointed
out the other day it's really important
that the same insurance companies that
will invent a fake dysphoria diagnosis
for a quote-unquote trans patient will
often refuse to cover health care for D
transitioners on the basis that they
don't have dysphoria
in other words in other words if you say
you're trans
then Healthcare Providers will happily
cook the books and say you have
dysphoria even if you don't
if you say you're detransitioning and
you're not a member of the preferred
class of transgenders then insurers deny
your coverage because your identity now
aligns with your biological sex you see
how that works
this politically motivated barbarism
which is totally incoherent is
supposedly the bleeding edge of trans
Health Care
you can see footage of Greg's call with
plume on Twitter and we published a lot
of it although fair warning as Elon Musk
said in response to all this it is uh
disturbing to say the least and it will
completely destroy your faith in modern
medicine assuming you had any faith left
which you probably shouldn't by now
but here's some of Greg's calls
twice a day yeah there's just a drink
right you got it
and then yeah
significant history all right
um
okay so let's let's kind of get into
this a little bit so you are seeking
what surgery
so for a couple reasons it's uh I might
be pronouncing it wrong but I've been
told orcadectomy right of course you
probably don't know the things that are
like irreversible when it comes to
um
estrogen-based therapy is breast
development and testicular strange right
but there's always a possibility for his
girl to come back that may that may
change in oriented
once you stop um when she don't know to
have your testes
um you no longer have the ability for
your teeth to convert to BHT but you
don't have as much teeth right so here
hair hair growth facial and body hair
may change
with outdoor camping fat redistribution
is affected by the estrogen
so you may have less of a change of
factory distribution if you ever stop e
but you may it may change as a whole so
it's it's kind of it's kind of um
it kind of does have a benefit without
the spiral lockdown but you still want
to take you still probably would
definitely want to take estrogen
I'm not I'm not complaining about the
daily pills just to be I'm complaining
I'm just saying if it accelerates it it
makes things faster that that's better
yeah just uh casually talking about
cutting balls off is all and you know
the one thing that well there are a lot
of things that jump out of you when you
watch that uh the clip and you see that
we have more footage that you can go the
Twitter thread and see but it's it's
this the Casual nature and Greg's making
no effort to you know there's not a lot
of acting involved in this on his end uh
it's just it's like yeah you know I've
been told I've been told I've been told
uh that uh you know I should get an
orchidectomy he pronounces it the wrong
you can't even pronounce the surgery
that he's getting
now maybe if you're playing Devil's
Advocate as you watch that you might be
tempted to think well Greg fooled them
he's a he's a master Deceiver
plume did nothing wrong you might say
they had every reason to believe that
Greg was really Chelsea Bussey and he
was really dysphoric and there were no
red flags in the call whatsoever
in case you're contemplating that
position for whatever reason I want to
zoom in CSI Style
on a particular screen grab from Greg's
conversation with plume
um here it is now
this is the moment that plume's nurse
told Greg about the consequences of
removing his testicles okay so this is a
man finding out what it means to have
your uh your testicles cut off
now I want you to notice uh again he's
making no effort at all he's making no
effort at all to to you know pretend
that he knows what what's going on when
he goes into this making no effort at
all notice his reaction to the news that
he's about to lose his gonads it doesn't
seem happy about it
you think that maybe the plume nurse
would have would have noticed that
reaction you think that would be part of
what she's doing is paying attention to
him and his cues and evaluating
of course she wasn't paying any
attention whatsoever to what Craig Greg
was doing during that call
they also didn't care about what Greg
directly told them
as he said again that he didn't have
dysphoria and yet they wrote a letter
saying that he had it anyway
that's striking because it goes without
saying that any reasonable and ethical
health care provider would have taken
one look at Greg and listened to him and
said this is ridiculous
or the very least a reasonable and
ethical provider would have pushed back
a little bit against the idea that Greg
needed his testicles removed but plume
never did that
they just took Greg's money and sent him
a letter authorizing his castration he
said he wanted it so he got it
did you know our friends at genusol have
upgraded the most popular package to
feature their top selling deep firming
vitamin C serum plus Ultra retinal
moisturizer with natural retinal
alternative well right now you can take
advantage of this limited time package
upgrade for 70 percent off why waste
time and money to go get work done on
your face when you can get genucel skin
care shipped right to your door JSL
secret is a family recipe for over 20
years that makes it safe for all skin
types and perfect for both men and women
made by compounding pharmacist in small
batches it's always safe cruelty free
and natural our production team just
hired a new intern named Finn so far
he's been doing a really great job
making coffee every morning but Taste of
my coffee is soured by his horrendous
hideous skin his skin is so dry and
Flaky I have to check my coffee just to
make sure peeled skin flakes didn't drop
into it it's revolting it really is that
bad uh and I'm definitely not making any
of this up it's a hundred percent true
but luckily for Finn we have loads of
genocell in the office which he's been
able to use and we have locked him in a
hole somewhere and thrown the lotion
and told him
it puts the lotion on its skin or else
it gets the hose again and anyway his
flakiness has finally vanished so go to
genucel.com Walsh and try join
yourself's most popular package for 70
off featuring both geniusell's Ultra
retinal and geniusell's Firming Serum
get a complimentary Spa Essentials box
with every package order plus free
upgrade to priority shipping go to
genyourself.com Welsh that's genucel.com
Welsh Congress once again allowed itself
to be pushed into appeasing the
administration and raising the debt
ceiling for the 79th time Paving the way
for continued Reckless spending and
further devaluation of the dollar as our
national debt continues to Skyrocket how
are you protecting your savings Times
Like These are a great reminder to
diversify a portion of your savings into
gold and you could do that with the help
of Birch gold the who I buy my gold from
so so do thousands of other concern
Savers as well Birch gold will help you
convert an existing Ira or 401K into an
IRA in Gold you don't pay a penny out of
pocket it's that simple when currencies
fail gold is a safe haven how much more
time does the Dollar even have protect
your savings with gold Birch gold is an
A plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau and thousands of happy customers
you can find out why by texting Walsh to
989-898 to get your free info kit on
gold again text Walsh to 989898
and as we reported on Twitter this fraud
extends far beyond plume several other
trans health care services that operate
in nearly every state in the country
like folks folx for example are doing
the same thing so so what now
that's always the key question after an
investigation like this what are people
saying about it is there any is there
going to be any change or are we all
just going to move on to the next thing
and forget about it well over at Media
Matters predictably they're hoping you
ignored our investigation entirely one
of their Flacks wrote this quote if
you're an adult you want to remove your
testicles it is not the job of a medical
professional to stop you and it
certainly is not Matt Walsh's job either
this is not difficult
the principle that the Media Matters
Flack is outlying is is indeed pretty
simple also stupid
it's that adults can do whatever they
want if an adult wants to carve up his
testicles then that's his right
well the problem with that analysis from
Media Matters is that of course first of
all it's depraved and insane
any moral person would not stand by
while someone else butchers themselves I
mean if you saw someone about to stab
himself in the stomach or cut off his
own hand or his testicles
you I would hope wouldn't sit there and
say well adults have the right to do
whatever they want
instead you would intervene realizing
this person is in deep psychological
distress and must be stopped for their
own good
rights have nothing to do with it just
like if someone's about to jump off a
bridge and kill themselves hopefully you
would try to intervene rather than say
well she's right
she's right
but this is irrelevant anyway because
patients don't remove their own
testicles
doctors remove patients testicles and in
the process these doctors claim to have
a medical basis for the procedure which
we have now proven is a total lie
these doctors cite standards of care
that we've proven are fraudulent
it is not a doctor's job to perform
whatever surgery a patient happens to
ask for
they're supposed to adhere to some
standards they're supposed to use sound
medical judgment
and none of that is happening
that doesn't concern the hacks of Media
Matters but it does concern actual
doctors for example Mary Talley Bowden
who completed her residency at Stanford
now runs her own private practice called
breathemd told us this quote every
treatment recommendation for musician
requires a discussion of risks versus
benefits and typically the higher the
risk the more extensive the discussion
orchiectomy requires general anesthesia
like any surgery could result in
Hemorrhage infection or death not to
mention devastating psychological injury
should the patient have a change of
heart it's not appropriate to declare
someone fit for surgery especially one
this major over a 22-minute zoom call
with a nurse
none of those complications came up
during uh Greg's conversation with Bloom
they didn't warn him of any
complications in fact and that's crazy
because as Bowden told us Telehealth is
quote appropriate for minor health
problems and low-risk treatments
by contrast orchiectomy is not a low
risk treatment
it often takes days to approve
Greg Jay march Market a surgeon and
OBGYN OB GYN was also horrified by what
plume did here's what he taught us quote
informed consent is a critical and
essential part of surgery in the absence
of any emergency is extremely important
that the surgeon or the representatives
assure that the patient is completely
aware of the nature of the procedure
being performed the likely sequela and
the risks benefits and Alternatives a
life-altering decision such as permanent
castration as serious irreversible
consequences the fact that a Medical
Institution was willing to undertake the
surgery only 22 minutes after the
patient requested this procedure is an
unforgivable departure from the standard
of care in any city in the United States
market and continue continued quote at a
very minimum a person undergoing
castration should have been alerted of
the long and short-term changes
following castration including hormonal
changes changes to cardiovascular risk
and changes to fertility and sexual
function instead this patient found a
user-friendly interface that they could
click through to get the surgery covered
even though they had just decided they
no longer wanted their their testicles
there was none of the EXT sense of
psychological or psychiatric counseling
that should have accompanied any
permanent surgical procedure for quote
gender affirmation I don't see medicine
here this is clearly the tool of a
political agenda aimed at mainstreaming
so-called gender affirming surgery in
order to achieve a political goal
I'm frankly terrified for any patients
who have been previously through this
process and are certainly at high risk
for regret after their surgeries
that's the consensus from every serious
medical expert that we've spoken to
after our investigation was published
yesterday we scoured news reports social
media for any contrary opinions from
credible people couldn't find any
now looks up Media Matters which we're
not counting as credible so the question
is if these trans Telehealth services
are so obviously fraudulent
what can we do about them what's going
to happen that will shut this down and
save thousands of patients from this
Butchery
as of today we haven't heard anything
from Aetna Cigna United Health which are
the three providers that work with plume
that's strange when you think about it
anyone who pays into insurance plans
from from any of these companies is
funding these fraudulent surgeries you
think that would prompt some kind of
response after all the more these
insurers have to pay for nonsense
operations the more they have to raise
the cost of other operations that are
actually necessary from a medical
perspective
but these companies as of now don't
appear to care about any of that we also
haven't heard anything from Craft
Ventures David sacks or the other
investors in Plume and folks we're going
to keep trying though we have reached
out to the Attorneys General of the
states where this fraud is happening
including in Tennessee we can't confirm
right now that the Tennessee attorney
general's office says that they will
look into this we're also waiting to
hear from Senator Marsha Blackburn who
we understand we'll issue a statement
soon
and we have received some responses from
other key officials Jack Johnson the
Senate majority leader in Tennessee uh
where both plume and folks operate issue
this statement quote another disgusting
attempt to label the mutilation of
children as Healthcare I appreciate Matt
Walsh for exposing this deranged
Behavior this is a real battle and it is
a real battle that we will win Tennessee
state representative William Lamberth
endorsed that post on social media
officials in other states have also
responded as well so far in Utah the
attorneys General's office has issued a
statement calling the reports troubling
saying that they are making it a
priority to investigate this kind of
fraud at the federal level
representative Lisa McLean of Michigan
is the chair of healthcare and financial
services Committee in Congress she
provided this statement quote only in a
country that lost its Soul can major sex
change surgeries be expedited like
buying a fast pass at a theme park this
is utterly disgusting and we cannot
continue down this path of insanity it's
time America wakes up to reality and
casts away Progressive ideology that is
literally putting people's lives at risk
Arkansas attorney general Tim Griffin
issued this statement which was somewhat
ambiguous quote Telehealth providers
operating in Arkansas must of course
follow our laws and I stand ready to
ensure that the law is followed now it's
not clear exactly what Tim Griffin is
waiting to see or what he's going to do
to make sure that trans Telehealth
providers will abide by the law we have
a lot of evidence that these Telehealth
providers are operating in Arkansas and
ripping off insurance companies in the
process hopefully Tim Griffin will look
into that after all it's his job
overall it's been only 24 hours since
our investigation was published and
we're already getting these responses
from officials who have the power to do
something about it
and we're going to make sure that they
do in fact do something about it
because that's what matters to us you
know we don't chase down these stories
and publish them just for the sake of
having viral content
we intend to get results and hold people
accountable
if we publish a story and it gets a lot
of attention and then everybody moves on
and nothing happens
to us to me personally that's a failure
we have failed
the results are all that matter and
we're going to get them
what we know for sure is that the
corporate media will continue to ignore
the story they don't want you to hear
about the scam that is trans
telehealthcare
the same media Outlets that lined up to
condemn condemn Ivermectin are telling
you that there's nothing to see here
well the truth is this isn't up to them
insurance companies are getting ripped
off which means that everyone paying
into these insurance companies is
getting ripped off
investors have been lied to which means
that they can pull their funding at any
moment
and several States now have more than
enough justification to issue subpoenas
to these Telehealth providers to see
just how fraudulent their operations
really are and how far this uh goes
if that happens a lot of people could be
spared gruesome surgeries that are
totally unnecessary
from any conceivable medical perspective
that's what's at stake
that's the whole reason we're covering
any of this
all it takes now is for our political
leaders to act on what we've uncovered
and we'll make sure that they do if
you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed